[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm Linc and
I'm Rhett this week at the round table
of dim lighting we have Elle and Blair
Fowler beauty and fashion vloggers and
real-life sisters their main YouTube
channels are all that glitters 21 and
juicy star o 7 both started in 2008
they've got a combined strieber base of
over 3 million in over 400 million views
and I gotta say I think that these
sisters are very very much responsible
for pioneering the style vertical on
YouTube that attracts so many
advertisers today yeah their makeup
tutorials and clothing hauls among other
related videos keep viewers coming back
weekly but the girls have expanded their
online personas to create their own
makeup line skylark
and handbag line with online retailer
JustFab they were featured on Teen Vogue
17 Mary Claire Marie Claire I don't you
know I'm speaking out of school here
Marie but I don't really know glam I
know glamour that's a magazine as well
as New York Times and Wall Street
Journal I mean that's that's kind of
thing I'm speaking a little out of
school here so I was excited to get the
backstory and to understand what makes
them tick you know they're they're
pioneers they're helping shape a medium
well because this is it this is a is a
huge deal I remember the first time I
saw a makeup tutorial video I didn't
will actually watch it perfect
personally perfectly
I saw your makeup wasn't perfect I saw a
thumbnail for it I was like that's weird
and it was probably one of these it was
probably either Blair or Elle I don't
remember and then I started seeing more
and more and just to give you some
perspective if you watch YouTube videos
on a regular basis you already know that
this is a huge slice of the audience
this is a huge slice of YouTube and
online video in general is the beauty
and fashion videos but this is such a
big thing that there are people like the
Fowler sisters like Michelle Phan who
have built empires around these videos
that started as girls in their bedroom
telling you how to put on makeup yeah
and as a listener you may not be into
this type of content style halls makeup
fashion and the like I mean but it's
still a great listen because as I said I
feel like I really gained in
right into two of the people who are
shaping an entire world of content
mm-hmm it's it's truly a phenomenon and
it's something to be reckoned with
right we talked to them about dealing
with online hate do they get an unusual
amount because of what they do we talked
about their relationships you know the
struggle of being online for so long and
being out there in the public eye
keeping those relationships private and
then what happens if they become very
public and plus their relationship with
each other I mean there's got to be
competition there what are the what are
the similarities between the two of them
the differences I you know it was fun to
explore that as well as answering
critics who say that their content is
too superficial should they be doing
more is there a sense of responsibility
there I get into all that and more here
it is our ear biscuit with the Fowler
sisters Bret and I we do wear makeup in
some of our videos quite a bit well I
wasn't gonna say quite a bit I was gonna
say likes sometimes if we have to I'm
gonna be like a famous shaving accident
and then we're shooting in a GMM I'm
like the makeup has to happen oh I don't
I'm gonna come right out and tell you I
wear makeup on every episode of good
mythical or nice y'all greasy my
forehead and noses well you don't have
to tell me I was just gonna cover for
you I mean no I cover myself with makeup
every time we get ready to film but I
don't really know what I'm doing so at
this point it is it's when you can say
guys it's okay to wear makeup well you
know it's totally fine if you'd like to
wear makeup but I I can't say that I
have been around a lot of guys on
YouTube that like to film wearing makeup
yeah what do you Tory what do you think
no I don't what do you think of that and
tell me the story that you're saying you
now don't have no I I think it's totally
fine I think especially if you can joke
about it but then if someone comments
and it's like wow you look like you're
wearing makeup and you get all defensive
and you're like right oh my gosh I would
never do that all that I just sit there
and I'm just like oh you wouldn't I
watch you I wouldn't you wear makeup on
camera though
completely normal for guys to wear it on
camera go in your everyday life that's
up to you don't do that you get to make
your own decision don't wear makeup in
everyday life on you don't look very
shiny jewel
he doesn't look shiny because he's
wearing makeup
no you know I mean I don't know maybe I
wash my face in this afternoon or
something now I will say I washed my
face ten minutes ago okay
sorry go you did yeah I did you wash
your face first I washed my face for you
you guys you got to understand something
about link though I wanted to have it
you should you can't you can be
flattered and you should be flattered
but link will wash his face like
sometimes I'll be like where is he and
then I'm I always in the bathroom
washing his face I think he's addicted
to it in that's kind of tell him it's
not good for his face to wash over wash
his face y'all notice right but I I mean
you apply makeup yeah okay I wear some
makeup in good mythical morning if I'm
like real shiny yes sometimes I'll okay
every time but I will just a little bit
just a little bit just a little bit it's
not like well it's not like eyeliner we
can just turn into a pirate show
mythical morning it did it is pirates
aren't mythical
they're real we're gonna turn you into a
unicorn that would make sense
well those types of pirates are a little
bit I mean eyeliner pirates if you go to
Ethiopia off the coast of Ethiopia
they're not wearing eyeliner no I mean
like Captain Jack Sparrow yeah I mean I
understand in my dreams
that's what they look like tell me about
the story of the guy who does it deny
wearing makeup now that we've come clean
I think he'll threw you under the bus
she was like has a story no I think it's
something that you're not gonna say who
it was as well but you could probably I
mean if I gave you three guesses in the
first two didn't count you'd still
probably be able to get it so I get
three guesses this is dangerous
yeah usually usually it doesn't we don't
put somebody this on the spot until
later on we let you off the hook we'll
come back to that but yeah I mean in all
seriousness I'm not ashamed
fact that yeah we wear powder I mean I
don't wear as much as a as an anchor
like a news anchor but this is our this
is our effort to try to connect with
your content because you know it's
because you talk about a lot more than
just makeup oh really like fashion do
I'm not being facetious I know you do I
make videos on my cat sometimes I make
videos on my dog sometimes this world is
expanding very quickly yep
but you don't have a home decor video
sometimes but if you have makeup advice
for us you feel free to give it at any
point
what type of translucent powder well are
you using translucent yeah okay which is
pretty good rice powder oh he's like you
need yeah okay what do you use rice
powder I use it I use this makeup is it
is it is that is that bad loose loose is
that no that brush no I use some sort of
little it's like a pad okay what do you
what is the other questionable yeah I
would use a brush yeah I say but a
different brush you should use a
different brush than him yeah because
his oil will go onto your face and then
you guys will both be oily that's
already happening
yeah get smile all the time that's been
happening for 3 to 5 years that's why
he's addicted to washing his face I did
notice your oil off my face notice if we
make a video where we hire a makeup
artist you know like some narrative
video where we're a music video or
whatever and they do other stuff what
brushes but then we're doing gmn on the
like I don't want to just be mr. shiny
man so I'm just like but I'm patting it
down a little bit
how often do you change that pad though
when the makeup runs out it comes with
the main bacteria that is harvested on
that pad we don't we we don't harvest it
we leave it on the pad oh it's you it's
harvesting harvesting it but it's good
bacteria right by the kind of isn't
yogurt no that's why I'm like well what
are you and right they're using rice
paper
we're using the right rice powder yeah
rice paper is a matte eyeshadow color
yeah that's the same color as rice
powder yeah so I need to be using a
brush you need a brush in you yeah you
need to not use that pad we should just
throw it away
remember when Julian Smith gave us this
really long tutorial on wearing makeup
and he said my aunt told me you're
supposed to wash your face moisturize
your face thoroughly and then put rice
powder on top of that and this that's
why you use it okay can't use rice
powder my cards do probably yeah I don't
know why I use it I mean nothing because
I just take the sheen off man no I know
that but I don't know why I chose that
because I was like I don't want
something with color on it because I
don't want it to look like I have makeup
on right and it seemed like yeah it was
translucent but can we just talk about
this all night yeah actually actually we
can't I've pretty much run out okay all
right yeah you can't we instead talk
about I think our other point of
connection is the South now y'all are
from Tennessee right so whereabouts and
where do you live now we live in LA okay
yeah do you live together we live in the
same building different units in the
same apartment we weren't very good
roommates we tried so hard
we just we didn't make it yeah if we
were a couple we would have broken up
okay okay
explain that tell me that conversation
we're just very different people as like
girly as we both are we're just
incredibly you know what it is we both
are OCD with neatness but only with like
the way we want to keep things neat so
we constantly were arguing over like the
same type of thing because we wanted to
keep things organized differently like
we just like very different on so many
things
we just we needed our own space so we
got our own space and now I know we're
like best friends again
yep that's how it works how bad did it
get we like screamed at each other we
never screamed at he I screamed at you
maybe I scream at me yeah maybe I
screamed at you and my mind so that's
another difference you're a screamer I'm
not a skel is not a screamer
do I ever scream have you did you know
have you ever hit have you ever hit each
other no
but so what was the fight over that
broke the camel's back
it was probably over that little cabinet
in our hallway in between our bedrooms
that I want to go into a coffee bar and
you wanted to how is there no stupid why
do you need a coffee bar upstairs when
there's one downstairs and you not walk
down a flight of stairs little corner
knows it would have been declares we
would have had to buy another
combination it would have been you know
we needed a place for our coffee mug
collection that we both collect so it's
half your problem okay but we had a
place in the kitchen cabinet above the
coffee maker who moved out okay that
means you were wrong no it means I was
very right well technically we both
moved out get our lease ended and but it
was her she's the one that was like I'm
moving I mean our lease was ended for a
while and we were doing like
month-to-month because I can't get our
stuff together and so but the
conversation - let's not continue to
live together was it your idea it kind
of the chips fell into our lap yeah to
do that because we were kind of
discussing getting our own places but we
were also at the same time looking for
condos together like we were still gonna
buy a place together and then we just
happened to find a building that had to
individual condos within our price
budget in the same building it just kind
of happened but the being in the same
building that's pretty cool gonna say
how often are you in each other's
apartments it's better than ours they
have much none of them are the same and
they all have a character on them and
did you make a video about this not yet
we got in honor of Teen Choice Awards
see if we have a little TCAP a were you
nominated yeah congratulations
and when did when did that happen that
was just like okay the awards are this
Sunday they they just a few days yeah
recently like last four days ago Monday
yeah so does the the red carpet now
first of all for women versus men I mean
the red carpet is of dudes just wear a
suit right you know and for girls it's
like it's big
everybody's gonna be looking at you the
pressure is on I mean this is like
heightened expectations so how do you
meet those expectations in one way like
it might fall off err no I'm gonna maybe
mine
well yeah yours might yeah um no it's
just every red-carpet event has a style
they all have like a reputation for the
type of dresses like the range that you
should be and the Teen Choice typically
you wear little short dress kind of
casual Billboard Awards you can get away
with anything you want it's a whole
range so we kind of went a little bit
outside of what would typically be seen
at Teen Choice no I will tell you one
thing by the time people are listening
to this it will have happened okay
they're googling right now so and we're
not gonna tell anybody any details from
this so I would love to know the
approach that you're bringing to this
and how you think people responded to it
so we picture so they can see it and
help describe so oh wow we are being
dressed by a really awesome designer
Michael Costello so we went into his
showroom and tried on a ton of different
dresses and we walked in we were driving
there together and I said we have to we
can do anything we want but we have to
pick short dresses like you don't see
long dresses at Teen Choice it's a
summary event it's casual and it's teens
a lot of teens are young and youthful
they don't wear gowns you're not doing
short dresses no you're doing tight
dresses they are tight known for our
body con tight dresses we pretty much
always wear tight dresses so mine is
like a hot neon yellow with a really low
back and an awesome like train that then
goes into this black fishnet it's so
cool
event so you've got like neon yellow and
then Elle's got like hot pink it's kind
of like you got us
you got a squint when you look directly
at a dress involved in this yeah I'm
gonna have I'm
have to have tape on the sides because
when I like glean for it it looks like
it's really tight but it actually this
area just kind of and I can't wear
anything under it because it doesn't
have a back
what is this glue stuff we actually were
just talking about this the other day
basically you know like that
double-sided tape you can buy at the
store like Christmas present okay
basically like that's not glue it's not
fun glue spray spray on
yeah hairspray no it's it's a spray they
actually have called glue for pageants
and it keeps your underwear from during
the swimsuit competition part of the
badges it keeps it from going up the
crack I don't know if you could spray
that on dresses though it might like
mess it up so fashion day you'd have
like a like a wet spot you don't want a
wet spot you know you just could be
strong enough no we need some hardcore
fashion yeah our fashion tape like it
hurts to peel it off your skin like it
peels my spray tan off has her dress
little tiny straps that are the only
thing holding on her dress and the way
her dress is is that she slips into this
the straps with her arms straight so if
she leaned forward if I'm entire dress
with just way if I like let my shoulder
pouch it literally just like just come
off it's not like a sleeve like a
typical sleeve where it comes from your
back how you gonna keep track of that at
all yeah I'm gonna keep my shoulders
back chest out you gnashing tape stuck
and and what happens when you when you
win and you have to go out there well
we've been nominated for three years and
we've never won so so chances are you
know who's to say who are you up against
in this category michelle phan bethany
mota graveyard girl zoella yeah okay so
good competition amazing competition
we've never been up against other beauty
gurus before and we've always been like
random web stars and they put you at
Black beat us the first year yes really
and but they put two together yeah yeah
we've always been nominated together as
a duo which is great because and then
one of us can't win well neither of us
have ever
we've never so even together
but maybe we weren't together one of us
would have won oh I didn't say me I said
one of us ha ha okay all right well
we'll let you guys work on that later
can you figure out the coffee bar so
let's go back to Tennessee okay and
continue the thread of being individuals
but then also having live life together
so how did it all start well we were
born in Georgia
okay that was I this is not about you
brother
huh not Georgia I'm I'm I'm interested
in their story okay well I gotta tell
him I was born in the same state Jackie
you can't expect me to hold that kind of
stuff back man we were born in Georgia
we lived there for until I was in fifth
grade and then we moved to New Orleans
for a year and then we moved to
Tennessee so we weren't until we weren't
in Tennessee till I was in middle school
and then we went over to Tennessee and
then L went to college and when she came
back it was between her sophomore and
junior year sophomore and junior
marriage of college I started YouTube I
was bored I was so bored so I was home
from college and I was bored out of my
mind you know I had been in college for
two years I was in a sorority I was
living my life like thinking my life was
just the best thing ever and then I came
back for the summer and there was just
nothing for me to do all summer so I was
like I need a hobby and so I decided
actually myself putting on makeup and
now this was before that that was a cool
thing to do I mean this really like
wasn't it wasn't really a thing it was
summer of 2008 and there weren't you
know okay so two years into YouTube ish
but no one was there were a few girls we
were all the very first girls but in
terms of it being you didn't see them
yet okay yeah the beauty community the
way it is now wasn't a thing what's an
assistant yeah why was that what you did
what made you say I'm gonna make this
type of video well I've always been in
love with beauty and fashion our mom is
really girly so mom's taught us to wear
makeup when we were really young if she
wasn't like a pageant mom she just was
very accurately wouldn't let me be a
Hajin I said yeah higher from the like
as young as I can remember until I was
like 16 I begged them to let me be in
pageants and they always said no and now
looking back I'm fine with it but at the
time I was very upset hmm yeah anyway so
they weren't pageant parents no I wish
they had been I wanted them but you were
schooled in the ways of makeup from a
very young age like on special occasions
she'd put a little blush on us I was
wearing a full face of makeup to school
every day by the time I was in sixth
grade and curling my hair every single
morning I was that girl really I would
have hair rollers like in my hair every
morning when I was like 11 yeah I look
back on that and I'm like what kind of
11 year old was I well I mean what's the
answer the kind that turns into a beauty
guru and she rose yeah the kind that
comes home from college and doesn't
really have anything to do and she's
like I'm gonna film videos of myself
putting on makeup were you trying to be
somebody or were you just was it you
were just really into it I definitely
wasn't trying to be somebody in fact
I didn't know at that point that you
could be somebody I mean this was before
I was even aware of the YouTube Partner
even amongst your friends I mean like
our friends for a year a long time took
us a year to tell them it was a bit
weirder well I actually I I was asking
the question as an 11 year old I was
still back there asking when you would
put your hair in curlers and invest that
amount of time and makeup in curlers and
you're asking yourself what kind of 11
year old was I do you have an answer now
as to what your mode is worth then was
it I'm just really into this as a hobby
or was it you were after the results she
wanted to look pretty for the boys at
school did you want to look pretty for
the boys wearing makeup I mean I didn't
really start wearing makeup but I was
also really into it yeah I liked it and
I I didn't resent the process I mean I
liked getting up early in order to do it
but at the end of the day it was because
I had a crush yeah who was this yeah who
was it his name was Josh and if my
friend Teddy is listening to this she's
gonna die you know what though can I
just say that my first first crush of
life yeah the crush I had in
kindergarten the first boy I ever liked
in this world I'm still friends with
what's his name his name is stone and
he's of course you liked him yeah yeah
he's one of my best friends still but
what when you when you Facebook Josh you
know all of my crush it's nice
my college crushes because by then
they're I mean by the time you're in
college you're pretty much an adult you
I mean you're you're kind of who you're
gonna be yeah but like the crushes I had
when I was really small with the
exception of stone he's still really
cute hi stone he's probably listening
but other than him
they're all weird every single one of
them every single one of us so your
judgment was clouded no I think I think
it goes to show that you don't want a
peak in middle or high school no
seriously I know that were like so
popular and you wanted nothing more than
to be like their best friend and stuff
like have you lost a girlfriend yeah
have you looked them up on Facebook like
it's it goes to show it's okay not to be
like the most popular kid in middle in
high school because you might be sitting
in Los Angeles doing a podcast and be
cool one day so yeah so Blair you're
saying you were not popular it was
always like so pretty though she doesn't
even know what she's talking about
except when she was two but then she was
really cute she had a little bowl cut I
some reason my mother thought it was a
good idea to give me a bowl cut like one
word at the cue today put the bowl on
your head and shave up to the bowl like
a little boy
okay maybe she's not confused maybe
maybe it's a possibility I think I think
the little boy in front of me got it
done in my mom was like oh so can you
put a bowl on your head and I was like
I'm gonna Bowl on my head and that's
probably how it happened so back to
junior year in college or before junior
year yeah you come back home you're
still you still have a love for putting
on the makeup and so that was your first
instinct to the type of YouTube video
you were gonna make well and she also we
live in such a small town
there wasn't a Sephora or anything like
that we had drugstore makeup that's it
but if you wanted to invest in higher
end makeup you had to order it now or
something like that you had to order it
online but when you would go read the
reviews you never really knew who was
reviewing it it could have been a
salesperson for the company and me I
wasn't thinking about deep I was know
enough about the process to think it was
a salesperson I just didn't think there
was a really good way to order products
online but your first video was a
tutorial it was so bad it's not up any
it's a yellow eyeshadow tutorial
who wears yellow on their eyes honestly
I mean you've done a couple
yellowish-white or you know what
bringing a full circle I use the color
rice paper I'm not
and that's that's the color that I used
in that in that cheese really yeah and I
didn't talk it was a silent video shows
were bad though I mean the quality was
back there wasn't it sound but the sound
was not the audio wasn't taking down to
zero it was just it's very slight
brushing yeah stuff like that maybe a
coffee are there no it's like you didn't
know the webcam was running exactly and
I was cooking at the web yeah it's
almost like someone put it where is
Grand except it was me subscribers
overnight and I'm like people are weird
and how long until you meet your first
YouTube for maybe like a week but she
had put up a video and then I remember
she came into my room at like 3 a.m. and
she was like I need to make you a
username and I was like what and she was
like I'm gonna make you a YouTube
account and I was like ok this is after
your video posted you got 10 subscribers
you're like you're getting in on this
like it's the most fun thing ever I'm
gonna film you putting on makeup and she
goes um excuse me
no I was in post videos of you doing
things in your bedroom by yourself on
the internet but I'm not going to so she
made my my username juicy star zero 7 I
have her to thank for that which now
looking back on it sounded good right
what was the thought process behind that
she asked me she was like she was like
well what do you want and like for your
username and she was sitting on the end
of a bed and right like behind her was
my coat rack with my Juicy Couture purse
and I was like I like Juicy Couture and
she was like ok juicy juicy star and
juicy star was taken so 7 so you go you
go back to college and Jan I didn't have
a computer anyway to film videos so for
the first year or for the first six
months I would only film like L came
back for fall break and then
Thanksgiving break and so I filmed a
couple videos and then she edited and
uploaded them for me like spaced him out
a little bit
so that it looked like I could have a
good answer I'm responsible for her
Channel yeah but what are your parents
thinking at this point my mom knew about
from the first night Blair did it but my
mom did like she was in on it she
watched the little yellow eye shadow
look the night I put it up she thought
it was weird but she was supportive our
parents have been supportive since the
very very beginning
weirdly supportive like it's a weird
thing your kids are doing essentially
back then because it wasn't a thing
right there was no reference point
exactly it wasn't back then how did it
start to catch on when it was slow slow
growth or something it was slow but you
know it wasn't that's like looking back
on it it wasn't that slow yeah well I
was working at a fast food restaurant
this whole time so because she was on
weiners I was I was the star of the
Weiner grill what restaurant it's called
power it's like basically like the
in-n-out burger of but they make policy
and we have hot dogs but there yeah when
you order it when you're like on
loudspeaker you have to call out like
Weiner and like she was a wiener girl
what does that do for your reputation in
a small town to be the Wiener girl you
know something she like no I mean really
online were my only like friends it's
also sad to say but like seriously like
I didn't really have anyone in town that
I was like talking to except the people
that worked at pal's with me and they
were awesome they were like yeah so I
was working at the fast food restaurant
and I saved up money over the course of
the summer and up until Christmas for
half of like the price of a macbook so
then for Christmas my parents paid the
additional money and so I got my own
computer and was able to start making my
own videos which was really exciting and
for some reason I was like you got
really addicted you really video every
single day for like 90 days which was
like unheard of at this point and we
were like I look back at it 90 days yeah
they were all really good video video
they were all like how to give yourself
a French manicure and I look back and I
can't do it to myself like the best how
to do a French manicure video that
exists like that I've ever seen yeah and
I was waking up but it wasn't immediate
traction with those it was just I mean
it wasn't like the views were going
through the roof or were they yeah
that's when they started like you see
star became juicy star was during that
90 day time period
she had her Rainbow Room and a lot of
times when people think of juicy star oh
seven they think of like her in that
time period
yeah what were you thinking too young or
anything like that and L what were you
think
when this started taking off were you
like hold on now second I mean I got you
started but I was still like cuz I had
been doing it for six months before her
so even when this was happening I was
still way above her she ended up passing
me later on but at this point it was
still like she was now also we didn't
mention we hadn't told anyone we were
sisters oh yeah you didn't know that we
were related looking back on it I don't
remember why we did that part of me
thinks maybe we were trying to be like
safe on the Internet
that's why it wasn't any reason other
than just also we didn't think it was
gonna be a big thing so we didn't tell
people and then there was a conspiracy
that came out and it was like Elle and
Blair Fowler said there's a new lonely
girl they're the same they're the same
person that's what it was this was right
around the time of the lonely girl thing
did you address it yeah and we were like
we're not a wrong person they're like
people would be watching my videos and
be like last time I saw you you had
blonde hair and I was like what that
wasn't me that wasn't my channel that
wasn't my video like but you didn't say
that was my sister no yeah no not yet
but then people started they they found
out I mean we lived in the same house
like with the same animals but you know
it was a sister the same animals is
funny but we never showed anything
outside of our own individual bedroom so
you wouldn't have known it was the same
house necessarily and really I only
showed the cats and you only showed the
dogs oh yeah we could have kept it
secret except for the fact that we have
the exact same voice and we sometimes
look like we're wearing a wig in each
other's color well this is an
interesting thing because having just
started to express yourself on YouTube
and then finding that you have an
audience and finding that you you're
becoming really really popular in that
you're starting to become scrutinized
you know and this is a good example of
it I think it goes even further in terms
of criticism which we want to talk about
but figuring out what's the what's the
line of privacy like even a quick
Wikipedia search you can kind of see
okay people talk about what are their
real names
I mean you tell the story but there's
question about well those aren't their
real names their legal names are
different and at some point you have to
make a decision are we gonna address
this when
first started I wanted to be incredibly
private like always been a super private
private person but I never did this
seeking celebrity in any sense of the
word I wanted to keep my online persona
completely separate from my real life
persona and when I started I didn't know
that was unrealistic I mean I didn't
know what path might my channel was
going to take mm-hmm
Blair wasn't like that at all if she
hadn't been my sister I probably would
have been able to keep a lot more things
private a lot of the things that came
out about us happened because this one
in there did interviews where she was
like all this stuff that like I would
have never put out there if people don't
know how to track you they can't track
you well this one here made it real easy
to try maybe you could find our address
because of this one here doing
interviews instead so ever so Ellen
Blair the names so L was my nickname
anyway that was the name I was going by
in college it was short for L for Lisa
and I've talked about how Lisa is my
legal name in like video a very long
time ago I don't bring it up a lot
anymore because at this point it's
controversy that's followed us for six
years but that's how it started and I
thought you know what I'm doing this
channel I'm not putting my last name out
there I'm just gonna go by my nickname
like why go by Lisa when I'm going by L
anyway and when for privacy reasons it
makes more sense regardless so I went by
out and then I'm glad I did because
that's what I go by
since she had gone by a nickname I was
like well I'm gonna go by a different
name and and Blair was not my nickname
before this just throwing it out there
but I never had gone by my first name
Laura I had always gone by my middle
name Elizabeth so I've always just had a
very odd name she had because when she
decided to go by Elizabeth which she was
a couple years old when this happened
yeah and I told him I would only respond
to Elizabeth I still called her Laura
for a really long time but I was the
only person that did it
so she always said you let her through
with Laura only her but I think I just I
don't think we actually talked enough
for me to care we weren't close growing
up yeah which you know we were five
years apart we were never in the same
school at the same time we didn't have
any friends that overlapped and honestly
our personalities weren't ones that made
us get along easily the funny thing is
though she slept in the same
that is me yeah our entire child like
her entire like you slept together yeah
yeah like she had her own bedroom but
she would come and get in bed with me
every single night don't call it we like
wouldn't but when you were awake do you
or not you wouldn't that weird a little
bit mom brings that up now and she's
like that's how I always knew that you
guys had potential to be friends one day
is you guys you slept in the same bed
loved each other as sister I was just I
was just scared of the dark did I let
you sleep with me every night when I was
like in high school so was the first
relationship initiative when you said
I'm making a YouTube account for you and
I'm gonna I did this now you need to do
it is that when you guys started to be
friends yep yeah YouTube but it wasn't
until so we started being friends like
she filmed like my first couple videos
and edited them for me and stuff like
that I still didn't get along so like
even I wish we had kept the raw footage
of those videos cuz it probably would
have been me I was rolling my eyes at
you and like we still weren't really
friends but then we put up a sister
video together and you can tell if you
watch it now like we can tell looking
back on it we were not close we were
like we weren't in like friends we
didn't even have fun filming that video
that video was hard to film but back to
the name thing whenever you were going
by L then you were like well I'm gonna
go by Blair
yeah well and she was she was older when
like she was had lived off for two years
from our parents I had just turned 15 so
when I was starting at my parents were
like you know you are still very young
yeah our parents told her she needed to
go by they were like buh-bye they were
like just go by a nickname her screen
name just go by juic star then and I was
like guys what was the transition
personally because well online as that
started to grow you were only known as
Blair right but personally do you Blair
from the day you started your YouTube
you guys switched from like Laura -
Blair yeah and she had never called me
and skipped Elizabeth entirely so
comfortable calling her Elizabeth but I
was the only person she went by
Elizabeth yeah everyone else in her life
yeah but everyone now cause you Blair
yeah personally like your parents young
and it's funny because I actually took a
guy home like maybe
a year ago and he ended up like after he
had like met my parents and stuff we
were just like sitting watching a movie
or something and he was like you know I
have to say I didn't believe you when
you told me that your parents called you
Blair and I was like it kinda made her
mad I was like why would I lie about
that like I would have told you're my
boyfriend I would have told you if like
you know yeah I'll tell you this I think
for some people they can look at our
name story and think it's weird as heck
and be like I don't understand there's
no way they go by those names in real
life they're not their names but the
thing is they are first of all and
second of all our family like I said
have always been weird with names we're
a huge nickname family like our youngest
sister I've only called her jelly jelly
in her life or well the interesting
thing for me is the challenge of having
to deal with this perceived controversy
because people were saying that we were
trying to our viewers that we were
trying we weren't and that's not what it
was yeah so that's why it made us upset
at first
did you in retrospect did you handle it
correctly no I didn't address it for
like four years just because I was like
dead maybe I did I don't know just at
that first summer this summer after we
started summer 2009 I was interning for
Seventeen magazine city and that's the
summer that hate started like we didn't
have it before then because I remember I
was living in New York when this hate
bubble started and when it started it
just like exploded characterized that
hate bubble what do you mean I've been
till that point we had a really amazing
like we might have had one comment that
was like you're ugly get off the
internet and that was like for like yeah
I don't have I don't think I got a
single comment like that for the fried
here I got it
yeah like I didn't get any like every
comment was so nice and we had never
been exposed to hate and it was that
summer I was living in New York and I
remember starting to get the little
trickles of mean comments and once they
started they just explode it exploded
and turned into this this thing where
like everyone who ever wanted to say
something mean to me saw someone else do
it and said I'm going to say something
mean to
and how did you deal with that each
other it was awful like I almost quit
that summer how bad did it get what did
you do I mean you cried a lot yeah oh
yeah we've cried a lot and really
considered quitting um it's you have to
remember especially when it wasn't a
career at this point we weren't really
making money off of it I mean there was
no reason to stay other than that we
loved it but it was fun that's the only
reason in the snuffle of it like and I
remember I would say like I would go to
school and I was being bullied at school
because of it because I hadn't told
anyone about it and then Seventeen
magazine did an article on us that came
out like two months before I before
summer for my sophomore year of high
school and I just I hadn't told anyone
because I've in my mind I thought that
they were gonna think I was like trying
to brag about it or something like oh
like you know I'm doing this and but
they found out anyway because it's like
well what if it doesn't have yeah and
then I was like what if I'm that girl
it's like I'm gonna be in a magazine and
then it doesn't happen and then and I
was like I don't want to brag about it
anyways but they ended up finding out
and I remember the day I walked into
school and like this huge group of girls
came up to me and they were like you
know we're gonna like beat your ass in
the lunchroom and I was like why like
I'm not sorry I was like okay you like
I'll see you there what's going on Amy
today they tried yeah but they I put my
hands up like this and then I ran away
and then I ended up I didn't go back to
my lunch room the entire rest of the two
months I ended up sitting in my fringe
teachers classroom so I just ate alone
in the classroom for the rest of the two
months and then I was allowed to come in
five minutes late and leave five minutes
early to go get in my car because then
they would start waiting at my car
is that what eventually led to you
dropping out of high school was that
related yeah well I didn't drop out of
high school I became homeschooled okay
so yeah my parents would have never let
me drop out of high school and I
wouldn't have wanted to you know just
for personal reasons but I became
homeschooled because of that yes but no
junior and senior junior and senior year
of high school yeah but she finished in
one year yeah what component of it was
I'm gonna make this a career was that
even on the table yeah or was it just I
cannot be in school
just it was just the amount of like
anxiety and fear that I had and it's
funny because actually L had she wasn't
living there at the time she wasn't
experiencing this with me my mom was but
then we ended up going out to a dinner
like two years later with we have an
online shop called glitzy glam and we
have like 10 employees for it and we
ended up taking everyone out for dinner
like two years later and our server
ended up like being one of the bullies
and we we ended up we left because I
just like just being in her presence was
just scary to me like and I'm not a
physical person like I remember when I
came home and I was like yeah tomorrow
if they come back up to me I'm gonna
like go like this and my dad was like
well if you do that you're gonna break
your thumbs so I suggest you like don't
try to eat me first of all everybody
everybody on the Internet is a target of
criticism but do you think there's
something especially about being a
beauty vlogger yes and what and what is
it specifically that you think brings
that extra grace or saying what who do
you think you are trying to teach us how
we should be doing like our hair and
makeup do you think you're that pretty
do you think you're that cool like all
that stuff and I was like no I just like
it like you know but I do think that
that putting yourself in that
marketplace and stuff I think that's
definitely why you can get more hate
more lately I believe that and for some
reason I think Blair and I are still
like some of the biggest hate targets in
the beauty community and the only reason
I can really think why is because we
were one of the first ones and we have
been easy to hate on for years we've
been easy to hide an easy target
yeah I mean I would probably hate you do
you think there's a difference in the
way you come across that invites it more
if you feel like you're getting more
hate is that it is that true I mean in
your when talking to if you talk to
Michelle or if you talk to the you know
the other names that you mentioned can
you are you able to gauge know what we
could do differently cuz we don't do
anything you know everyone says that
they get it and stuff like that like
when we judge them about it but I think
that just personally looking I just feel
like I feel like my bigger targets I get
it you know or maybe there's two of us
maybe it's I don't
I don't know I think Blair gets it more
than me but I think we get it more than
anyone else really in the community how
do you deal with it nd is it worth it
it's so worth it which is why we're
still doing it six hours later I just
had my sixth youtube birthday woo me too
yeah she did too I've noticed with prank
channels they seem to be getting laughs
at people's expense you'll see that they
start to do the type of pranks they say
see I'm not that bad of a person see how
I help this person do you feel like that
you there's some sort of PR thing that
you could do to say I'm you know just
kind of put yourself out there more no
if you if you cried in a vlog and people
felt knew how it hurt you would they lay
off is it guns because we've kind of
done that before where mentioned that
it's it's hard before and they're like
well then why are you still doing it is
it worth it yes absolutely without a
doubt their lives that be so different
and it's right that aside I think the
question really comes down to that first
summer 2009 when we first started
getting hate we weren't being paid yet
so we didn't have like it's my career
and this is my livelihood and all that
argument backing it up it was purely a
question of do we like this enough to
deal with all of this hate and we did we
stuck with it what has been the net
effect of dealing with that type of
criticism it's just and now you've got a
perspective that this is just part of
the deal if we're going to do this this
is what we're this is part of it but and
you've you're seem to be in a good place
with how you deal with that but it
obviously has affected you in some way
like how do you think you're different
because of the criticism that you've
received we've a really thick scan we've
grown a thick skin and I think it also
we are really good at heping each other
up if we see the other one needs it like
we might joke about how like you know we
don't live together anymore and like
stuff like that well like we joke about
how we were bad roommates but living
together is what bonded us so much it is
yeah and then we can be joking and if
she's like I just don't feel like
filming today stuff like that and you
know there are times where I'm like then
don't just go get in the movie go get a
tattoo with me let's get drunk but I can
also tell when their time
that we do need to push each other and
she's a really good pep talk giver
she'll come over she'll be like you're
still pretty
I could be an inspirational speaker one
of the things that that we've noticed is
that the vast majority of YouTube
comments can be just frustrating but
then every once in a while there's
something that you read and you're like
I don't like that but you know what
there's some truth in that mainly ones
that obviously the ones that are like
you should go kill yourself and you're
so ugly all those sort of things like
I'm not obviously gonna listen to those
but I get a lot of constructive
criticism like you shouldn't pump your
mascara wand like that before you put
your mascara on it puts bacteria like
back into the tube like things like that
a lot of people are like then we'll jump
on them and be like that's so mean why
would you say that but then I look at it
and I'm like thank you for telling me
that so like constructive criticism I
definitely take away like a lot of good
things from but it's just the
straight-out mean comments but I've also
said a lot of times I don't actually
think that we should call them haters
there are haters out there but for the
most part I feel like a lot of mean
comments on YouTube are just people with
different opinions that have a rude way
of saying yet or they're just having
really bad days yeah or they're just
unhappy people sprinkleofglitter was
talking to us recently and she made a
really good point she was saying you
know when you're having a great day and
you are just like so happy and
everything's going so well in your life
you don't find the need to be hateful
yeah you're just having a really crappy
day or if you're just a very unhappy
person and you're sitting there and
you're watching and you're like that's
wrong and that's wrong and that person
like is doing this wrong and stuff like
you want to expel it hear someone down
to build yourself up yeah
and as a result it's almost sad when you
read those comments because you have to
think like what are they going yeah you
never know someone's family life and you
know what six years ago when we got a
mean comment it was the end of the world
and now we can read 30 of the meanest
comments in a row and I yeah glad that
our skin has gotten so tough with it
because it's almost like it means we've
been exposed to so much hate that we're
like numb to it now which is actually
kind of sad but it works in our favor
because we have to deal with it all the
time by virtue of the
type of content you create I mean a lot
of it is focused on how you present
yourself to other people so it's I mean
it's by definition external in a lot of
ways how do you think your content
contributes to how girls think about
their self-image we're very open with
our viewers I mean we talk about we we
have bad days and you know we're
definitely trying to show confidence on
the inside and on the outside that we
aren't doing these like makeup videos to
show you how you can be pretty or
something like that we want to show you
how you can enhance your prettier yeah
feeling better it's your natural
features and feel better like walk with
the Lord understand if that doesn't give
you an extra pep in your step then you
don't because I certainly wouldn't yeah
I feel better when I'm wearing but I
yeah like it genuinely makes me like a
better day it does yeah yeah and that
might be people just say but like I
think it's a personality thing not every
girl that exists out there is gonna
watch our videos and feel like if I
spend an hour doing that every day I
feel like my life would be happier but
it really does make every aspect of my
day I like love getting up in the
morning yeah making a cup of coffee and
like doing my hair and makeup it's mine
first of all yeah then you feel
confident all day yeah I mean if you
don't look that good that day I mean
sometimes we do our makeup and we still
don't look that good but it's not about
how you look as much as like you feel
like okay and it's like a routine put my
hour in and now I feel I look the best I
can I'm like Superman with my little
costume on I would imagine that you get
criticism on what you're focusing so
much on the external what about what
about the inside yeah you know I don't
really get I don't I don't really get
that either and you know we could do
videos where we talk about like the
charities that we donate to and stuff
like that we don't because that is
something that we feel like if you were
to do that like it's just kind of
showing like oh look how good of a
person I am I actually don't really get
criticism yeah and I really yeah I don't
really get that having established
yourself with the type of content that
you do do you ever feel like trapped by
the genre do you want to try other
things
because we and do anything yeah cuz we
do do what we want to do like if we want
a daily vlog we daily vlog if we want to
do a book review we do that if we want
to do a video that's 30 seconds long on
my cat running around I put that on the
Internet and how do people respond to
that because from the very beginning
we've done that though we've never put
ourselves just we've never pigeon holed
ourselves yeah one type of we've always
been a little bit more like just
anything in Ellen Blair's world that we
want to put on there we do so so you do
have the freedom to create different
types of content or different types of
videos that you can connect with your
audience in different ways oh you said
earlier I could be a motivational
speaker you know when you were talking
about when when Blair needs that pep
talk and you're there for each other to
deal with that
has anyone prescribed to you you know
what you should also make videos that
address the internal I've been requested
to do advice videos before and the
reason that I haven't done them is
because I just feel like Who am I to
really give them advice on the inside I
don't know it's kind of one of those
like Who am I to give them advice on the
outside either I don't know but if they
want to learn from me how I put on my
makeup like I'll teach them that I just
feel like giving advice on how someone
should live their life I almost feel
like I don't have the authority to do
that unless I knew him in real life and
I knew their situation but that's why
I've never done it I just feel like Who
am I to sit there and be giving it we've
also been really careful from the very
beginning we've always said you know
we've never had any sort of professional
training on this or anything like this
is how we do it
this isn't maybe how you're supposed to
do it we might do it really wrong yeah
and we're not the best we've never been
the best we've never claimed to be the
best we never will be the best no on the
internet there's there's this value of
being transparent and the more you can
connect with your audience the more
people eat that type of stuff up
there's certainly people of all ages who
were just gushing about whatever their
opinions are and their perspectives but
there may be people who are thinking
when you give advice about the external
there is an opportunity to be honest
about what's going on on the inside too
if your self-image is not tied up
totally in how effective your makeup
makes you happy
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that but I'm I guess I'm asking the
question is there more to the picture of
what makes up your personal self-image
that there might be potential for you to
share that with your audience just as
food for thought not okay here's my
advice of how you should view yourself I
mean we try to put a little bit of that
in our videos but I think as of now
we're not doing like full videos focused
on that we could but we just have it yet
I guess it would require a number of
things not the least of which is a
vulnerability that is your right to not
not have to go there yeah I guess I was
curious if you ever got that feedback
people said well you've got these girls
watching you and they're eating up all
your advice related to make up anything
you say they're gonna they're gonna take
it to heart so give me that motivational
speech about what matters is your what
matters is what's on the inside I've
talked to them before kind of loosely
about like the bullying thing and I gave
a little bit of advice on that and I did
get a good feedback of people saying
like I didn't even realize I was a bully
that liked what I was saying could be
hurting someone and that way and stuff
so I think we do little things like that
but I mean yeah I know we haven't done
like full videos yeah and I think you
bring up a good point with the privacy
thing for me is I've never really I've
never talked about relationships I've
never really brought friendships into my
youtube channel and I've I would have
never brought my family into it was it
not for this one doing it first it's
hard because it's like if I was just
beauty and fashioned and I could say
well I've always just said I'm only
gonna do beauty and fashion but that's
not true because I kind of do anything I
want if I want to put up a video of my
cat it's hard I don't really know where
the line is even for myself I've always
just kind of been in a little bit of an
open book yeah except lately I have been
putting relationships online cuz after I
did that the first time in let's talk
about relationships yes with Sawyer
that's what you're referring to so in
retrospect well what would you have done
differently what happened wasn't a
youtuber when they first started dating
first of all I mean I didn't even tell
him I was a youtuber I told him I worked
in beauty marketing because if I go to
if someone's not in the YouTube space so
you started dating him and then you got
so you got him you got
you're harming into YouTube oh yeah he
hadn't done it for like the first six
months of us dating or something
so you're still friends yeah okay I mean
yeah we we just did a collab video
together where right he spit a lot of
water in my face how was that I was sick
for a week afterwards so gross yeah I
was yeah it wasn't from him I mean I
don't know if it was from him that I was
sick for a week after ya draw your own
conclusion mine was gross he was
carrying something that's what I thought
lol told me you know be careful putting
like a relationship like that online yes
I've never openly talked about any
relationship I've been in in a six years
I've been on YouTube in fact a lot of my
viewers are convinced I've never had a
boyfriend or a lesbian which is very
poor yeah yeah which is very untrue just
a little bit of searching I find that
okay they say you've got a boyfriend I I
do have a boyfriend you're in his videos
and she tries to be very private about
her okay
that's a weird exception because he's
also public but I will say that we kept
things very hush-hush for a very very
long time I don't know anyway um but I'm
talking about back when she was with
Sawyer at this point I had had three
boyfriends in that time period none of
which I had breathed a word about on
YouTube so when she started dating
Sawyer he wasn't a youtuber he wasn't in
the world well and I did not tell
youtuber Twitter about him he did so
I'll just throw that I don't remember
that all I remember you giving her
advice to keep it off the internet
because that's how I had done it and
that was just my big sister and it was
really now you're trying now but it's
difficult okay but the music video thing
was done is a fat one yeah that was just
it's cold that turned into a really long
time you make a music video with
somebody and next thing you know you're
it's more serious we have a really long
history we've been friends for a very
very long time I was in his music video
as a friend as a maid
I thought it was a documentary I'm sorry
now but now it's interesting because we
have talked to many people at this table
about the about this issue right
this whole relationships and YouTube and
you had there's this weird thing because
as youtubers we're all more open with
our personal lives than a typical
celebrity would be right but at the same
time you usually know more about
celebrity relationships than you do with
youtubers because they tend to be more
restrictive about that particular part
of their lives do you feel like there is
I mean just like link said I mean a
little bit of searching and you can find
out what everybody is saying about your
current relationship yeah and that's the
first time that you've ever been able to
really do that with L with the exception
of like one person because I have always
dated people completely out of the
public eye so it's very easy to keep it
completely secretive when the other
person isn't a youtuber or a celebrity
yes they're just normal people every
single boyfriend I've had in the past
you can't find any pictures because I
have a personal Facebook that's private
are you concerned about that
relationship now that it's public I mean
it's public but it's still very private
like they don't really know I've never
confirmed it yeah I think you just
confirmed it I'm sorry okay you haven't
confirmed it that's fair that's fair
we'll go with that well and then I think
like with Sawyer he kind of claimed
himself I remember when he tweeted
something that was like yes for those
asking I am dating at juicy star
double-oh-seven and I remember thinking
you have like seven followers and not a
single one asked you that so I don't
know I hooked it all of their Twitter
pages no one asked you how pretty sure
no one had any idea but then he did
decide to start a YouTube channel and
he's done very well with it I will say
he has worked very hard to get it where
it is but since this is because I've had
that public relationship since trying to
date then and I'm single right now
painfully and so if you guys like know
anyone like I'm I'm single and ready to
mingle you know
we get it noted you might get a few
tweets for that I mean I'm just saying
like I would you want to start a family
I do yeah immediately yeah I do
yesterday but anyways trying to do
really do then yeah yeah she's really
weird right now it's like really odd
that I've like I honestly believe I was
put on this earth to be a mother and you
want to get pregnant oh yeah I mean yeah
I want to be a higher aid first she
wanted to be pregnant for like when iers
like when my mom got pregnant I was only
nine years old my remember being really
jealous I'm not sure I knew where babies
came from but like I was really upset
that she was pregnant and the stork
hadn't brought her a baby right you're
still getting a lot of tweets at this
point but they're from a different demo
yeah okay all I'm saying you might have
some volunteers one single that is
actually a good person like would be a
good father
I mean IQ that's like that's like my
number one thing like when I go on a
first date I scare so many guys away
because I ask them I'm like do you want
kids and she says when you're like you
realize you're 21 and I'm like let's say
you met you went on a date blind date
with someone tomorrow and I'll give me a
time give me your being serious yeah
it's give me the for real first date
tomorrow night with Jake Jake okay you
know it would probably be a little while
until we became boyfriend girlfriend
like probably like two months is right
right good less for you are you kidding
so say it like two months that's gonna
be really creepy and then I want to date
for about two years before we get
existed is August first so two months
will be it's not August first let's say
it okay
October ok October 1st October first so
then we could get engaged like fall of
2016 and then I need a year to be
engaged but I could I could take it down
a couple months if I wanted to get
married in science after no no I don't
be I don't want a honeymoon baby I would
I would want to be married for at least
a year before I get pregnant and just
like travel with my husband and stuff so
realistically 30 yeah no realistically
I'm not gonna be having my first baby in
two like 26 if I met
one tomorrow night so that's why I'm
saying like I really need to get on this
okay it's already been it's like nine
years you should just go on married at
first sight right so uh how do you feel
yeah how do you relate to this what's
your what's your baby-making plan I
don't really want kids I want like three
or four but I am I don't have a timeline
like she does okay you're going to let
it happen yeah I've never been that kind
of person she's always been that kind of
person that's always happened like I've
had my life planned since I was like
nine yeah it was not in the cards guys
like I should be married by now actually
but listen we wish you the best in that
and a general request you know it's been
really cool getting to know you and
being left behind the curtain of beauty
vlogging guru dumb dad having us on you
know it's great we had the double-sided
tape pulled back and well and now you
need to sign the table thanks for coming
in there it was our conversation with
the Fowler sisters Elle and Blair got to
say I'm not feeling too good about this
makeup situation I'm talking about our
personal makeup situation oh you still
you're still time there yeah the whole
time and we talked to them after they
mentioned the bacteria-laden pad that
we've been applying to each other's
faces not just our faces but we've been
sharing well I've been applying to my
own face we don't like reach across and
like apply to each other's face I'm not
your makeup artist and vice versa but I
think it's important to note that we've
been doing that for years not not with
the same make I mean this this
particular pad that we've been sharing
for it's probably this is probably three
or four month pad could have been a year
no but I'm saying even back in the early
days of high digital 8 cameras when we
knew that we weren't supposed to be
shiny and we went to Kirk our drug and
ro right aiding and got some makeup
we've been sharing we've been sharing
some makeup brother yeah we might need
to rethink that and our
we're going there to have to to buy like
a replacement it's like what shade do
you get well I got the tan summer shade
and then I got the winter paler shade
yeah right and but I still cannot make
sense and what do you do domestic cuz
I'm in your in the wood space you put
your face up next to it and guess you do
if you match yeah we know so little but
we it's not a man there's not a men's
makeup section just you know for like
hair dye there's a just for men's
section there needs to be a man's eye
makeup side and it probably works no
different than the women's hair dye but
they just market it to men and they put
it on a different aisles so that men
don't crap their pants when they have to
make a decision if color hair you know
it for men it needs to be the makeup
section needs to be way smaller and it
just needs to be a it needs to be this
machine that you walk up to and it takes
a picture of your face and then it just
tells you what you're supposed to get
that should be in LA I mean with all the
guys wearing makeup out here there
should be like a like a red box for
men's makeup I don't think you can
justify more than that but it's like a
food needs to be a booth that you can't
see a guy in there cuz it'd be ashamed
it's like going to a strip club or
something there's like a a wall that you
have to park behind yes right yeah you
park behind a wall and then you get in a
booth and get makeup okay well we'll
continue to work on that the Fowler
sisters are gonna continue to work on
this beauty and fashion empire that they
have created yeah let them know what you
think of the year biscuit tweet at them
Elle Fowler and Blair's is juicy star
double-oh-seven
so let them know what you think hashtag
ear biscuits also let us know yes and we
look forward to you being with us next
week we do not wear makeup while we do
here biscuits I do want to make that
clear because you don't see us and have
not announced a makeup on right now be
proud to say it and proud to say I want
next week
[Music]
[Music]